está afectando la salud de los
trabajadores del subterráneo esta
exposición al asbesto sabemos que ya
perdieron algunos de sus compañeros
verdad
Sí gracias por la comunicación es así
tenemos tres compañeros fallecidos
noventa que están afectados seis de
ellos que han desarrollado o están
desarrollando alguna etapa de cáncer
producto de la exposición con este
material que en nuestro país está
prohibido desde el año 2003 que se
debería haber retirado y que los
gobiernos y la empresa concesionaria no
lo han hecho por eso estamos reclamando
este plan de retiro de asbesto reducir
las jornada para minimizar los efectos
de la exposición hasta que se retire
definitivamente como marca la ley y
varios fallos de la justicia
cuéntenos Claudio Cuál ha sido hasta el
momento la reacción del gobierno de la
ciudad
Lamentablemente el gobierno de la ciudad
que es el dueño el principal responsable
del subte del del metro en esta capital
en los primeros años cuando detectamos
la presencia de del asbesto primero lo
negó negó existiese y después de que las
pruebas fueron irrefutables lo que está
haciendo es tratar de minimizar o de
desconocer directamente los riesgoso que
es para los trabajadores y también para
los millones de usuarios y vecinos de la
red de subterráneos que están en
contacto cotidianamente con él más allá
de el tiempo de exposición el asbesto
una sola fibra puede contaminar y puede
terminar desarrollando un cáncer y matar
a las personas de esta gravedad estamos
hablando y la actitud que tiene el
gobierno y la empresa concesionaria es
criminal porque no da la respuesta que
corresponde ese es un punto clave
Claudio que muchos no han tenido en
cuenta O no se ha reportado porque esto
afecta también a la salud de los
pasajeros no solo los la de los
trabajadores cuéntenos Cómo van a
continuar con su reclamo Podemos esperar
nuevas medidas de este tipo para los
próximos días
seguramente vamos a tener que seguir con
medidas de este tipo de paralización del
servicio y otras hemos realizado muchas
medidas muchas de ellas no afectaron el
servicio hemos presentado también frente
a la justicia diferentes reclamos De
hecho hay un Amparo colectivo que tiene
un fallo favorable en primera y segunda
instancia y no tenemos otra opción
porque en definitiva de lo que se trata
es de defender la vida de los
trabajadores que somos trabajadores del
subte pero también la de los
trabajadores que son usuarios del
subterráneo de la ciudad de Buenos Aires
Esta es una pelea que no puede terminar
de otra manera que con la solución que
es la de esas vestimentación integral el
cambio de las flotas que están
contaminadas la vigilancia médica para
todos los trabajadores y la reducción de
la jornada como te decía para minimizar
los efectos de la exposición a este
mineral